we're getting everything ready aboard
this ship here the Aleutian research
vessel what we've got on board Alisha is
we're good - sobs both subs are
thousand-meter rated we probably on
board the ship do the most thousand
meter diving in the water to have this
moment in time but we are just about to
enter there remember the Pamona this is
a big moment in our trip we're just
arriving at the Blue Hole this blue
holes about 300 meters across sent us
about 90 meters deep we're going along
and mapping this to the sea bottom with
a 90 degree beam underneath the ship you
can then modify that to make a beautiful
picture of the sea bottom so what these
guys are doing is they're taking core
samples of this sediment in the bottom
of these blue holes the idea is to learn
when the Hurricanes have occurred in the
past and they can go back almost several
thousand years if they get down low
enough and when they cut them open
they're looking at layers of sediment
just as a geologist on land might look
on a mountainside at layers of earth
that way so this episode is about
climate disruption in the sense of
storms hurricanes naming I'm from
Louisiana
I know a lot about hurricanes I got
involved because this is a story that
needs to be told
climate change is real it's man-made and
as a result of that we are heating our
oceans to a place where storms are going
to be more frequent and that spells
trouble for all of us there's nowhere
else in the world that holds such
high-resolution records of these storm
of big bends so being able to look at
these archives into the past truly gives
us a great understanding about how we
can expect these storms to be changing
as we move to a warmer climate with a
higher sea level this particular
expedition is
a dream come true we're basically taking
these submarines down into these giant
blue holes and studying them when they
bring that thing down and they gently
rested on the seafloor and you realize
I'm literally 300 feet below the surface
of the water what is down there is the
key to our history and therefore it's
the key to our future